[موسيقى]
لا نستطيع تجنب الاستنتاج من ان
الجهود حققت الطشلا في النهايه حققت
ازدهارة لافغانستان في البدايه
هناك ضعف الاشخاص الذي يستطيعون القراءه
في افغانستان اليوم مقارنه ب 2001
واغلب الافغانيين لديهم كانت الوصول الى
الانترنت وحتى لديهما هواتفان قال لم بكل
لديهم في عام 2001 كما ان معدلات الاعمار
ايضا ارتفعت بشكل كبير جدا
وافغانستان
على العقد الاول بعد عام 2001 او اكثر من
اي دوله اخرى اما الان فهي تقاس بقاعده
بطيئه جدا ولا تزال بين افقر الدول في
العالم
[موسيقى]
نحن بالتاكيد نتحمل مسؤوليه ولكن
المسؤوليه الاساسيه تقع على عاتقه
الطالبان هم الذين استولى على الحكم وليس
نحن
ولكن نعم نستطيع ان نقول بان الولايات
المتحده مسؤوله عن تصرفاتها
ونستطيع ان
ننتقد او نحكم على سياسات الولايات
المتحده حسب النتائج والنتائج مخيبه
[موسيقى]